un moment donné dans les discussions
on en arrive finalement à dire il faut
présenter un dossier vous encourage à
présenter un dossier vous proposez un
dossier et un moment donné vous avez une
discussion sur l'association et vous
nous dites
vous avez proposé trois quatre
structures d'associatif potentiellement
pouvant faire c'est ce que vous avez dit
on est bien d'accord
donc ça veut dire de manière très simple
que à un moment donné le cabinet vous
dit vous ne pouvez pas prendre l'action
j'allais dire en non personnelle bon
ça aurait pu s'imaginer
contractuellement bon mais on souhaite
en fait non pas travailler avec
l'association on en connaît aucune des
quatre c'est pas le sujet c'est on veut
travailler avec vous et donc
l'association servira à porter apporter
l'action quel que soit ses éventuels
compétences donc c'est ça le sujet le
sujet
c'est que l'appel à candidature qui va
venir derrière même si on vous le
présente pas encore
c'est un appel en tout cas vers des
structures et donc il faut que ce sont
des associations qui répondent et c'est
pour cela que vous répondez avec le SS
on est d'accord on est absolument
d'accord avec une précision sur les
quatre associations que je cite 3 était
totalement connu du cabinet
ah pardon et donc refuser pas refuser
la seule qui connaissait pas je d'une
certaine façon c'est pour ça que je me
sens trahi aujourd'hui je me sens trahi
par les mensonges je me sens trahi par
les approximations et je me sens trahi
par la politique de l'amnésie qui est
mené dans ce dossier
encore une fois je rappelle je n'ai pas
sollicité de subventions on m'a
sollicité je rappelle que l'association
j'ai cité plusieurs associations je les
ai laissés choisir l'association pour
les amener dans une logique de
coopération en est on est censé être
comme on pourrait pas permettre moi
l'expression dans un même bateau donc on
est en confiance avec qui souhaitez-vous
que je travaille que je mette en
application ce projet il y a je connais
un tel je connais un tel je connais un
tel non non un tel je suis là non c'est
quoi ça ça c'est voilà et ça s'est passé
comme ça ça c'est pas passé autrement ça
s'est passé comme ça toute une autre
toute autre récit et mensongée je le dis
que celui-ci d'autres non la question
que tu es posée c'est pourquoi cette
association vous donnez la réponse voilà
je pense que de bonne foi mais il faut
pas voir du mal partout pardon
d'écrire des faits alors
on voit que vous savez que les gens qui
regardent n'ont pas tous votre votre
intelligence pardon c'est pas il faut
pas qu'il vaut que les gens voient du
mal partout
c'est plus de la connaissance voilà donc
voilà restons sur les films
la reconnaissance d'utilité publique
voilà qui les intéresse c'est quand ils
ont bloqué sur la reconnaissance
d'utilité publique voilà et c'était le
seul critère finalement qui a permis de
dire cela d'ailleurs a été a été dit par
par un des deux préfet semble-t-il on
peut retrouver quelque chose autour
cette notion effectivement d'intérêt
public mais on est bien d'accord en
réalité il y a un appel à projet de pour
des structures dans votre cas
particulier on souhaite travailler avec
vous vous n'avez pas de structure vous
reposez quelques structures qui peuvent
accueillir cette action et le ministère
en choisit une voilà
pas de on est d'accord